e
e e
good morning welcome to the special
committee on due process and
dcyf um I'd like to open up our meeting
and um and welcome everybody for coming
I know that we're a little thinner on
attendance today but um this is one of
the challenges of getting into the time
period that we're in in the house uh
we're trying to make sure that nothing
else is missed in our bills that we're
working on and making Mak sure that they
all get through to the Finish Line um I
had hope that we would be able to have
some appointments with some of the
agencies however um some are yet not yet
ready to come um they are ready to
respond with some written answers others
have meetings that are scheduled right
now at the same time um so this may
likely be a shorter meeting and the next
meeting um instead of setting a date and
hoping that we'll be able to get them in
um I will be working with them and then
working with the committee members so
that we can have have a meeting that's
scheduled when they are available um
also the house takes a break over the
summer so we won't be coming in I
believe is it July and August that we
don't come in correct so July and August
we will not be here um so hopefully we
can get some get some good things done
before that I know personally one of the
challenges that I've had is that there's
not really sharp edges between what is
dcyf and what is in the family court so
I know that as I'm working through
something and trying to understand
something a lot of times it ends up
being part of the family court issues
they actually have taken some topics
over to the special committee on Family
Court to address some of the concerns
that we've raised
um so um one of the interest one of the
big questions that you know as we do
this we'll be going through our
committee researchers pulled together
some fantastic research that I'm going
to distribute to the committee so that
we can have some um some better and more
productive meetings as we move forward
um and
and quite frankly I I think that this is
important I think we we'll be continuing
on we'll be hearing from people as well
and um I wanted to see if anybody on the
committee had anything that they wanted
to bring up before we wanted to hear
from anybody that's here representative
long uh thank you madam chair the the um
pcyf Advisory Board is meeting uh next
Monday the 20th okay I I don't know if
there's something you would like me to
bring actually representative sidel is
also on The Advisory Board
if there's something you would like us
to bring to The Advisory
board thank you thank you just yes I
actually think that I'll come in sit in
and watch and see that because um
because dcyf is an area that i' only
been perer peripherally paying attention
to previously uh before being involved
with this I know that um I know that
it's a very very important topic but I'm
still learning a lot right now so I will
come and watch that great thank you
and is there anybody who'd like to speak
to the committee are you just here to
listen you'd like to speak yes okay um
do we have pink cards
sorry no I didn't take them thank you
very much
yes yes I will put that on the committee
site yes and the other materials I'm
still I still need to make sure that
they're appropriately redacted so that
there's not personal information in them
um there's been very important
information but the last thing I want to
do is violate a family or child's
privacy um by accidentally putting
something out there that they'd rather
not have lived forever on the
internet
yes it's a delicate balance you know and
that's what the challenge is too with uh
dcyf and and the concerns that we have
just making sure that families and
children are respected it's always it's
always a very delicate dance where
people um I believe we're always trying
to do the best they can but we're
humans okay
sorry and I guess procedure wise I
shouldn't have been having a
conversation with unmik people in the
back
but that's all right
and uh thank you David um Killy or Kylie
Kylie Kylie David Kylie if you'd like to
come up and
speak and so we want to keep this
focused on policies not people um so
it's not about names it's about what
happened
and it's also about um not family court
because there's another sub another
special committee on that it's a focus
here on DCF and the procedures within
DCF especially due process so with that
I'll stop interrupting and welcome you
to
speak can you hear me okay yes thanks my
name is David Kylie I am from ainson New
Hampshire um representing myself and
people and wrote this out so hopefully
it sounds as good as it came off my
fingers but uh each of the members on
the committee here today I imagine when
it's a public service due to an
obligation to a higher purpose whether
to correct Injustice improve the public
domain or perhaps just to make
government work better and protect our
private
rights uh which is the essential which
essentially is the is the purpose of
government keep in mind you're here
today at the request of the people not
those in some administrative
because people like me have witnessed
legislative tribunals endangering the
private lives of people I personally
don't have firsthand knowledge relative
to New Hampshire DCF but I unfortunately
witnessed family loss as a result of its
sister franchises and two other states
on two separate occasions one only a
little over a month
ago the reason for my testimony today is
based on um witnessing and firsthand
knowledge of direct interference with
the people's right including my own
provide lawful instruction to
representatives in this house and even
members of this
committee the natural order of authority
flows from the mandates of their
creation just as an artist controls his
works or an inventor controls the ideas
his ideas or as I believe God controls
the time and space of our existence the
people create a government we told you
what the government has allowed and not
allowed to touch those mandates were
written out ahead of time organized into
into a document
and no one can no one can serve unless
they to agree to its terms mostly by
oath in turn the government creates its
agencies which are two ordinances below
its creators people over the past months
I've been told things really don't work
that way or you just don't understand
I've seen social media attacks relative
to this
committee
by PE on people by reps of our house
simply for stating what it's written
and labeling people like me as
right-wing nut jobs even making lious
accusations not on me personally about
being convicted felons scammers child
abusers accusing regular people of being
radicals or wanting to tear the system
down well since one is holding any agent
to any term of an agreement a radical
idea if you're not part of a system if
you're not part part of a system that
values political perspective in
sophistry over the simple words of an
agreement who is really the radical so
perhaps you don't feel like you can do
much perhaps you think you can only
write more laws and feel powerless to
punish those that break the laws we
already have
perhaps the general court has been
granted the Authority for for Grand
inquest as as well as the power to
impeach even for not showing up with
these hearings I would imagine I ask you
today to stop interfering with our right
to instruct focus on the truth
especially to that which has been sworn
according to the laws of the land and
quite simply constitute evidence when
unrebutted I ask also ask that if you
are part of or support the gaslighting
that's going on in the public space
please knock it off these are serious
issues that's it thank you thank you
very much and thanks for coming to this
committee there any
questions thank you
Donald Donald
Gilbert good M good morning Madam chair
Representatives so many of you have seen
me before uh many of you have heard
Snippets here and there of the problems
and the tribulations and some of the
fixes that need to go
on so kind of to just break it down I'm
going to give a brief overlay of where
things are obviously there's a Great
Divide between some members of Our House
of
Representatives you know and as some
Representatives uh spoke last week at
the uh meeting for on DCF that happened
you know sidebar in a sense um you know
they they said that we need more
immediate fixes and and I don't think
anybody's here saying that there's not a
problem that we don't need those fixes
immediately nobody's saying that you
know we can't work on those long-term
you know due process and you know
abolishment or or whatever be the case
but the situation currently is we have
dcyf and particularly two offices in our
state that just absolutely refuse to
follow policy procedures court orders
or even advice from the office of the
child advocate and the Attorney
General's office
um without naming them you know it's
known to this committee it's known to
many members that this is a
problem um it's known to the DC wife
advisory so there's a stark reality that
we we can go ahead and act enact
whatever legislation we want
if if they're not following the
legislation that's on the books
currently what's going to make them
follow the legislation that we
enact so that's the real issue currently
is somebody needs to step in and start
holding these employees that refuse to
follow the court orders refuse to follow
the law held accountable uh and that's
just simply not happening and you know
when people are questioned on that they
jump ship you know as the most recent
director did as former director ripsom
did um if we go back to last year at the
family special committee on the family
courts um former ribom former director
ribom went ahead and testified the
biggest backlog for them is the criminal
court
system and that's just one key aspect is
they refuse to do their duties while
there's a criminal case and that's where
half the aisle wants to focus is putting
everything on the criminal court case
and that's just simply not a possibility
at this point because the criminal side
of the justice system is slower than the
family court side of the justice system
um we just finished as some of you may
have been informed we just finished a
two and three4 year court case as my son
will put it that was closed out as
acquitted on all charges where for the
last two and three4 years I have not had
contact with
my and that's a problem that was that
was strictly on there was nothing
holding me except those criminal bail
conditions DCF had already closed their
case we had already resolved dcf's side
of things and it was the only the
criminal bail conditions that precluded
us from having contact so there there's
a problem with trying to just simply
abolish DCF and put it all to the the
criminal courts because the criminal
courts clearly are not ready and you
know the answers from the judges were
well co co you know we due process
rights don't matter because of covid you
right to a speedy trial doesn't matter
because of covid you're right to the
speedy trial doesn't matter because of
this or that you know so we won't get
into that too much but you know the
situation is is that backlog was all at
fault of the state we had three trials
that M ended in a mistrial at fault of
the state we had seven attempts at trial
in the last nearly three
years at fault of the state getting
postponed part of that was because DCF
was refusing to turn over records that
they still did not turn
over um that's a big issue that this
committee has obviously heard multiple
times over that DCF refuses to produce
evidence both in the family court and in
the criminal courts uh there was a
supreme court hearing last year on
another case where one of the counties
had to drop the case because it the
superior court ordered that the DCF had
to turn over those records and the
Supreme Court upheld that and DCF still
refused to turn over those records so
they had to drop those criminal cases
because DCF did not want to turn over
those
records so there there's a big issue
here with 170 g8a where they're willing
to turn over records to certain parties
and and refusing to turn over records to
defendants and to you know those
petitioned in the family courts uh we we
currently are still battling in the
Family Court um as some of you may know
that we're sitting waiting for records
and we got an email from the supervisor
saying well we don't want to give you
those records and we're waiting for a
court order to exclude you from having
those records well the problem is is
you're trying to say that there's a
problem here but then you're telling the
judge
and the petitioned parent oh you can't
see what the problem is you can't see
the evidence that we
have so we're sitting in an issue
where you know they're saying oh we have
all this evidence all this evidence but
then they want to lock it away and hide
it away and not let anybody see it
including the
judges and in both family court and
criminal court so as you can imagine
some of you have seen some of the
reasons why in our particular case why
they're trying to hide that evence away
and I've spoken on that is the fact that
we had three children in our family
abused under DCF
supervision and that is confirmed 100%
by the Attorney General's office they're
still investigating both the DCF workers
and the individuals responsible for the
abuse and severe
neglect um so you can kind of see you
know when something goes Ary
they're just like don't look here don't
look
here um and that
was where our position is of where this
that criminal case even came from
because the whole time this County and
DC was solely focused on trying to cover
up what was going
on on the other side of the aisle rather
than actually focus on my son the
criminal case was not focused on my son
it was focused on on just something
totally different which I won't you know
get too much into
publicly but at that same time three
months before that The Stepfather was
charged with criminal charges of child
pornography he was under investigation
for those sex crimes against these
children and I started speaking up about
it because they were still leaving my
child in that home they were still
leaving the other alleged victims in
that home with that alleged perpetrator
in violation of his criminal bail
conditions we had 169c protective orders
put in place for the children and DCF
was violating those 169c protective
orders for those children they not only
were violating it back then they
continued to violate it until November
of 2023 when the Attorney General's
office was investigating them for
perjury and investigating them for
violating those criminal bail conditions
and protective
orders so and and this is not not unique
to my family or my case or my children
or anything this is happening in a lot
of cases in those two district
offices and again the committee knows
exactly what offices those
are this is happening to many families
it is absolutely ridiculous I I don't
understand why these employees are still
they they have lawsuits against them for
other child fatalities I I just don't
understand I mean I understand because
obviously the state does not want to
terminate these employees and admit
fault for those child fatalities but why
we keep compounding the issues and
allowing them to continue to create more
severe issues for children and families
and for the state I I don't understand
why we're allowing them to be
involved um so that's kind of the the
backdrop of everything you know for the
last three years per se um the the real
kicker obviously like I said 17 G we
need to ensure that they're just turning
over record you know they have a problem
saying that oh we can't turn it over
because of third party or whatever well
the court orders say including third
parties like so we we're not going to
you know 170 g8a even says unless
there's a court order that says you can
turn over those third parties you know
and you know the courts are ordering for
those third party records to be turned
over and they're still saying well we
can't turn them
over
um so that's kind of the brunt of what I
wanted to kind of say today I guess I
mean it's still a work in progress as
many of you can imagine
but you know that's and if you have any
questions that's where I'll leave it for
today I
think thank you representative
love thank you Mr Phil with you be
testimony where were where was it you
said you lived I live in Tilton Tilton
okay thank
you I'm represent on thank you madam
chair so when did the case close the
criminal case okay so all right so the
DC that was a criminal case so the DCF
the DCF side of that Criminal Case
Closed out in July of
2021 and the criminal case for it was
acquitted on May 3rd of this year
repeat yeah so July of 2021 was when the
dcyf case closed as found uh so they've
closed it out as problem uh founded
problem
resolved I still don't know how that
happens because they did not offer any
sort of services they did not even
interview me they did not give me my
parental Bill of Rights uh I can't talk
too much because there's still an a
appeal going on that um for that finding
but as you can imagine there's a problem
with them closing out as problem found
uh found a problem resolved when they
offered no Services they didn't even
come to my home I have other children in
the home they didn't even go ahead and
interview my other children to ensure
that they were safe so there's a huge
problem that I'm trying to drive home to
them that I will hopefully be able to
talk to soon about publicly that you
know there's a problem here you you
can't just say oh the problems are
solved check the box and and walk away
because not every parent is not abusive
like there are parents that are actually
abusive and actually neglectful that are
actually founded and whatnot we're not
just doing something maliciously to try
to circumvent something else like you
didn't do anything you didn't check on
that other child that's in the home what
is what if that actually was an abuseful
situation
and that other child was being abused as
well you just let that child sit there
without being checked on so I have a lot
of problems with how they handled that
which I'm still trying to deal with
again like I said there's an open aaou
matter on that so I don't want to get
into too much details um but I hopefully
will'll be able to come back next month
because they're working on their
internal with their Administration and
Marine Nunan and the OCA on trying
to tidy up and figure out that yes there
is a problem Mr gilbertt and you know
let's sit down and actually work to fix
it thank you did you have a followup
representative than for taking my
question again uh how many children were
involved in uh you you said the some
were removed and some weren't uh could
you so so there is seven children
involved in the family this particular
incident there was only two children in
the home at the
time uh only three of those children are
actually my biological children and the
two oldest are full
siblings can you explain that again sure
thing so I have I have three children
the two oldest children of the family
are 14 and 13 currently those are full
biological
siblings the mother has another four
children after that that varying age and
then I have a third child who is 7 years
old who was in the home at the time of
that
incident and again dcyf never checked up
on that child DCF never didn't that's
where my problem is with my appeal my
appeal isn't because they found it a
problem and because I I know how you
know unfortunately the system is they
just say oh yep we believe you know it's
by a preponderance of the evidence we
believe that the child was abused our
finding is and this is how we're going
to work to solu to fix it that's not
what they did they just went ahead and
said there's a problem Oh the problem's
all set
had Mr Gilbert charged
criminally maliciously um we'll get into
that another day but um because they
turned over evidence without a subpoena
warrant as well um in violation of 169c
and their own
policies um so
yeah thank thank you for bringing this
to us again this and I'm so sorry for
everything that your family's gone
through with these challenges it's it
sounds like a really difficult situation
um I'm thankful that you found those
different resources because um I I I
guess the office of the child advocate
wasn't around when this began in 2021
because it's a more recent creation or
was it at that
point as a just start it was just
starting out
and I'll just say part of that was part
of our doing as well um our cases have
actually been going on since 2019
so and these investigations into the
other side of the family have been going
on since
2018 so you found that the office of the
child advocate is one of the good
resources for families families to go to
and for children to go to in order to
have another perspective um and to be
able to Advocate although I'm sure it
has it short everybody has their
shortcoming so obviously they're a
little overburdened but they have made
an effort for the last last 15 months
almost 18 months I guess now to meet
with myself on a month at least a
monthly basis um they have provided
direction to DCF the Attorney General's
office has provided direction to
DCF that local office just simply does
not want to hear that
direction thank you and the Attorney
General's office did they get involved
because of work from the um Office of
the child advocate K or from um a
different process or if you don't know
how they got involved so I would say
it's a little bit of everything okay um
enough sign there yeah multiple people
filed perjury allegations last summer uh
I think I spoke on this last time I was
here and if not it was at one of the
other committee meetings last summer
last June one of the children was
sexually contacted by the adults in the
home and DCF left that child in the home
and then they went ahead and testified
in the Family Court saying that there
was no issues inside the home there was
no issues allowing these children to
have contact with this person in
violation of his bail conditions and his
protective
orders uh obviously we had another case
where Juvenile Justice went ahead and
told the court we had two cases one for
Juvenile Justice for my son uh there was
a chins case that was open because
subsequently um um so Juvenile Justice
went ahead and told the court what was
actually going on in the mother's home
and the truth about everything well the
cpsw side in that local office went in
in the afternoon and said everything was
fine and dandy there was no issues in
the home and that they were advocating
for contact with the stepfather who was
again still under criminal Veil
conditions for the child pornography
charges and he was still under
investigation for sexual abuse of these
children
they he's been under criminal
investigation since
2018 and those to my knowledge and from
speaking with the police department are
still active and open so we just don't
understand why dcf1 was violating the
bail conditions but again then
advocating in court saying it was
beneficial for these children to have
contact with this person in violation of
bail conditions and protective
orders and um that's why you are at the
aaou because there is an investigation
being done in order to make in order to
follow up and see what happened and why
that happened as a as a derivative of
the Attorney General's office getting
involved no so the aiou is the appeal of
the finding of abuse against myself for
that criminal case that just closed so
that a has been pending for two and
three quter years just about as well two
and a half years and again like I said
DCF closed it out as founded uh finding
with a problem resolved well they
offered me no Services they offered us
nothing they never did a home visit
excuse they refused to even connect with
me or even tell me what the problem was
that was the biggest issue of it um so
that's the basis of what my appeal is is
how are you going ahead and saying this
was problem resolved how did you even
come to this finding in the first place
when you refused to invest and tell the
alleged perpetrator what they allegedly
did you refuse to give parental Bill of
Rights you refuse to conduct a home
visit and ensure that the other child in
the home was even safe and secure so how
are you closing this out as problem
resolved when you didn't offer any
services and the situation I I I know
what the situation is because I've
talked with the office of the child
advocate and this happens in many cases
they were banking on that criminal
charge to end in a conviction so that
criminal aspect would take care of their
duties and alleviate them of the
problem the problem is is obviously that
didn't happen so now now they're sitting
down there well I guess we're down in
conquered right now but they're sitting
over there at the state complex
panicking trying to figure out what to
do because that criminal charge didn't
bail them out and there is a problem
like their problem was not
resolved there's a lot of ongoing pieces
there I apologize for ting that part
wrong have you connected with the office
of the abund at DCF so that is a big
problem that we actually need to address
as well I feel I don't know how we go
about it so because there's an active AA
case the office of the ab budsman
refuses to connect with and that's in
statute well it's in admin rules um that
the office of the ab budsman is not
allowed to engage with a person or a
family who has an active aaou
case because
DHHS uh handles the administrative
Appeals Unit and obviously DHHS also
handles the ab budsman
office so they refuse I forget exactly
what uh admin rule it is but there is an
admin rule that
disallows the ab budsman office to
engage with parents that are in an act
of a
Au thank you for providing that
information that's uh definitely
something to look into that that's seems
challenging to me do representative long
did you have a question or is it I I did
actually thank you uh throughout all
this will you Pro say what did you have
an attorney so in the family court I
have an attorney that obviously the
state has
provided obviously the criminal case the
state provides an attorney for the
criminal
case um everything else and in the aeou
I am proos say
and unfortunate for DCF I am
obliterating them in the Pro proceeding
of the aaou
but okay thank you so I I do feel that
that's an issue though um that the aaou
and I think that's one of those things
that you know that other side of you
know the iel keeps bringing up is with
these tribunals is that there is no
representation there is no facing your
accuser in those AA proceedings
I I do feel that that's something where
realistically if we're going to find a
problem and say there's a problem and
take a child way we should do it through
the family court rather than through the
aaou you know you're going to go ahead
and say there's a problem and put a
safety plan in place and say you can't
have contact with this
child and then give no representation
give no hearing on
it you know obviously that a you know
the protective order and whatnot not is
already closed out that safety plan is
closed out but that's how it starts is
they go ahead and open the case they put
a safety plan in place they say okay
there's an issue we need a safety
plan the safety plan's only good for you
know two weeks a month at the most
usually
and did you have a
question
oh sure thing so
um so yes so they open that up and then
they go ahead and finish up their case
assessment whatever it's supposed to be
within 30 days um that usually does not
happen um
and once that finding is done that
protective order is closed
out well in this situation obviously the
criminal bail conditions precluded the
contact well those criminal bail
conditions are closed out and no longer
and I mean I went and had contact with
them the same day that the equid
happened so that there's a problem
there representative
Weber thank you and I'm sorry for the
interruption uh what I need to sort out
um I I understand and I I I absolutely
think that perhaps we ought to um alert
the DCF advisory committee that about
the issue of release of records that
that needs to be
explored um but what I was trying to
figure out um it sounded to me like you
were saying that the aaou process was
involved in removal of children and my
understanding is that the aaou process
is
for the grievance the arises out of the
proceedings it's not the actual removal
and in fact there was no removal in this
case part of which is one of your
concerns is that correct have I got that
right yeah so I guess I didn't do the
the best job of explaining that
obviously there's a lot compated there
are a lot of moving parts so I just want
to make sure I
understand so where the gears are not
meshing so in theory if you follow the
procedures and how they're supposed to
happen they're still supposed to be
meeting with us on a monthly basis for
home visits while this AA is open
they're supposed to be having a safety
plan in place while this aou is
happening they
don't you know that's a problem but the
thing is is so with that I guess it's
not that they're taking children with
the aou but they're taking your your
rights and liberties with that that
finding of abuse you know like right now
there's a finding of abuse well I can't
go work in a school I can't work in a
daycare I can't go work on a a bus you
there's many places I can't work in a
nursing home because of that finding of
abuse now I'm not saying every employer
goes ahead and checks the central
registry but they have the ability and
they have the legal right to check that
central registry for that finding of
abuse so there's a a problem there where
you know they're going ahead and saying
there's a problem they're going ahead
and saying oh the problem for this
particular Avenue so there's three
Avenues there's founded sent to court
there's founded problem resolved and
then there's
unfounded so the issue is the problem
resolved really is where the issue is
that that Avenue kind of just needs to
disappear and if they're going to find a
problem then it really needs to be sent
to family court
or you know because it's it's taking
away your Liberties to work I mean it's
not
necessarily taking your children from
you but if you have another allegation
of abuse they automatically open that
for an
assessment you know right rightfully so
but the fact of the matter is is so they
go ahead and open that up they put a
safety plan they take your child away
for 30
days to decide what they're going to do
with the case that's still impactful for
the children I feel
anyways even for that 30
days thank you very much for
yes so yes and I'll have an additional
write up I mean I have a 300 page
article that will eventually go out
we've been working on it we had most of
it ready for the uh special committee on
the family court but because of obvious
reasons we kind of delayed on releasing
that and you know we will still delay a
little bit longer while this a is going
and then we'll get that out to everybody
so I would ask with that that you
include a summary 300 pages is a lot
there there will be a summary but for
the ambitious folks there are some there
will be some ambitious folks that will
want to dive in and understand exactly
pinpoint on how everything came to be
and how everything happened and how we
can actually fix
everything thank you representative long
um what the dcyf ADV committee um could
you also um ask about the conflict um
between not being able to have an aou
and um work with the umman at the same
time okay and um the question about the
founded resolved having no no court
involvement so no opportunity um for a
hearing representative
Weber and I would just add to that um
there there often is no court
involvement if it's if it's founded but
um resolved but it seems to me that if
it's founded and the person's accused
have not been told what was
found that would be an
issue yes I mean not being told what the
basis of the the issue
was is
uh very problematic if that if
that's quite frankly how could it be
resolved if don't know what the problem
was well
and and obviously that's one of my big
things that you know they're sitting
over there with their attorneys trying
to figure out what are we gonna do now
now that well we don't need to assume
what they're doing um I I think part of
the reason why it was a lot easier to
hear all the different information that
you brought is because there were less
of the names and just focusing on the
issues because um I do know that you
brought this to us but it's a lot more
clear removing the names and removing
all of that because it's a lot more
obvious exactly what's going on with the
moving pieces so thank you for being
able to do that and bringing that to us
not a problem so thank you for having me
thank you any other questions thank you
very
much and uh there's one other topic that
I think is also very important for us to
figure out how to get our hands around
it um I know that the title core
especially sitting in on finance in
division three we had some discussions
about some of the title four funding and
those implications for some of the
policies that we're moving forward on um
I would like to have a better
understanding of title 4 its
interactions with
DCF um what it requires what it
prohibits and how it influences the
setup of DCF its interface with the
family court um to me since it's such a
complex issue my question um especially
to representative walner is if it would
make sense to um have in the budget
requests that they can outline and spe
specify when Title four is included
because I know that that has an impact
on what we would be funding and what we
otherwise would be funding so that we
can understand the implications um of of
the federal requirements going
forward well it's I think it's certainly
something we should maybe bring to the
attention of the legislative budget
assistant and as um the department is
getting ready to um put together its
next
budget have the legislative budget
assistant maybe work with them around
what's possible as far as um deciding of
those those funds thank you um so with
that do you think it would make sense
for me to talk to Mr Ripple and get a
better idea of how to ask my questions
once once we get through this period
with the bills needing to be passed sure
that sounds reasonable thank
you and are there any other questions or
comments from the committee
oh sorry representative love he I've
been uh thanks for taking my question or
my comments um I've been working with a
constituent um I believe I brought it up
uh she had uh her daughter had uh had
three kids taken away and adopted to a
family in
Florida they left one child the SM the
youngest child with them once again tell
me some rhy or Reason here the most
vulnerable they leave but they took the
the three older ones um you know it's
it's uh I can't I can't wrap my head
around it I I can't for for the life of
me figure out what's what's going on if
you if you're going to take three please
take the if there if there's reason to
take three please take the most
vulnerable the youngest one and uh and
they didn't um it it it just doesn't
make any sense to me and we' we've got
to figure out you know the the rhymes of
reasons why they do
things it it's I just keep hearing story
after story after Story things that
don't make sense thank you we'll put in
a request specifically for those
policies and procedures around how they
determine which children stay in and
which ones are removed yeah um so that
we can understand it because it seems
that that's not as unique yeah just it
seems like Mr Gilbert's story fed right
into it the same thing happened
and that's a very good
point thank thank you all for your time
and attention um I I will make sure that
um I can try and schedule with the
office of the child advocate or anybody
else who can come in and provide
information um it would be good to um I
I'll see who whom else I can also bring
instead of scheduling a meeting and then
hoping that they'll be able to attend um
I will reach out to them and then reach
out to the committee members um to
confirm availability so that we can
schedule so then we'll we'll schedule
that in an upcoming calendar and once
again in July and August the legislature
is off so hopefully we'll be able to do
this and get something done in June um
because I know that that is quickly
approaching so with that I will close
this meeting thank
you e